vous
le meilleur chef d'armes de l'humanité,
hein,
le chef d'équipe a été amélioré et
formé dans un seul but
pour gagner cette guerre,
lui et les autres spartiates
sont nos seules armes efficaces contre
l'alliance
[Musique]
voici des forces d'alliance mortelles
évolutives
et surtout
contrôlables
qui semblent creuser
une sorte d'objet
quand j'ai touché l'objet j'ai ressenti
quelque chose
je me sentais
différent
ce qu'ils nous ont
fait vous fait connaître et vous venez de décider de
m'aider pourquoi un spartiate ne ferait-il pas cela
que fait-on avec un surhumain
vous n'êtes pas sûr  vous pouvez faire confiance
bonjour maître chef
je suis cortana
maître chef récupéré quelque chose de sacré
anneau halo
[Applaudissements] les
humains se
rendent à l'alliance
cortana je vais avoir besoin de toi maintenant
trouve le halo gagne la guerre